[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportage sur Public Sénat la promesse
vous le savez elle est dans le titre de
l'émission donnée du sens à l'actualité
vous proposez des clés de compréhension
des crises que nous traversons et ce
soir c'est un double droit de suite que
je vous propose un retour sur deux
événements majeurs de ces derniers mois
d'abord la mort de Marsa Amini c'était
le 16 septembre 2022 cette iranienne de
22 ans avait été arrêté trois jours plus
tôt parce que son voile ne cachait pas
assez ses cheveux sont décès provoquera
une révolution de la jeunesse contre le
pouvoir des molles
nous devons choisir ce que nous portons
et comment nous comportant
et personne ne peut nous toucher
et c'est pourquoi je pense que cela
continue
pour moi c'est une révolution permanente
et les hommes sont là pour soutenir les
femmes c'est tellement beau
les manifestations ne font plus la une
de l'actualité mais que reste-t-il de
cette révolution réprimée dans le sang
réponses dans une minute et puis pour
notre second débat notre seconde droit
de suite nous remonterons jusqu'au 5
juillet dernier la fin de 10 journées
d'émeutes qui ont frappé 516 communes
dans 66 départements métropolitains
français un déferlement de violence
déclenché par la mort de Naël tué par un
policier lors d'un refus d'obtempérer
plus de deux mois plus tard qu'elles ont
été les réponses judiciaires et
politiques que faut-il attendre du plan
banlieue que le gouvernement doit
annoncer le mois prochain réponse dans
trois quarts d'heure mais d'abord retour
sur ce mouvement cette révolution ces
trois mots femme vie liberté en Iran
avec Matthias arez
quelques jours après la mort de Marsa
Amini tué par la police des mœurs ces
images jusqu'à leur impensable le
drapeau iranien piétiné par la foule
mais aussi ses femmes par milliers qui
retirent leur voile et coupe leurs
cheveux à visage découvert sur les
réseaux sociaux ces manifestations de
colère à l'encontre de la loi obligeant
le port du rijab réclame la suppression
de la police des mœurs en un an la
répression est violente plusieurs
centaines voire milliers de manifestants
sont emprisonnés ou tués par les forces
de l'ordre des agissements dénoncés dans
les pays occidentaux
oui nous lutons tous ensemble et nous
voulons être la voix des Iraniens ici en
Europe
nous avons définitivement atterri dans
un moyen agislamique et nous attendons
des gouvernements européens qu'ils
apportent un soutien en particulier à la
jeune génération la jeunesse iranienne
ne veut pas de ce régime
10 régimes d'une radio
les protestations sont moins visibles à
l'international mais continue sur le sol
iranien notamment grâce aux étudiants
nous sommes au côté des étudiants et
professeurs qui ont subi la pression des
institutions de sécurité de l'université
au cours de la dernière année et nous
résisterons à la répression l'université
et le centre de la liberté
d'autre part la situation économique du
pays minée par l'inflation prend à la
gorge la population la situation se
dégrade de jour en jour les gens vivent
difficilement nos autorités devraient
d'abord assurer de bonnes conditions
économiques le hijab est une question
tout à fait secondaire et personnelle
dernier projet en date des Gardiens de
la révolution iranienne la création d'un
Internet national afin de couper leur
pays du web mondial
que reste-t-il de la Révolution quelle
forme prend ce mouvement aujourd'hui on
en débat tout de suite avec mes invités
faribas Troudi bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes écrivaine journaliste présidente de
l'association morcen ashroudy Moha qui
se fait les codes la voix de centaines
d'étudiants iraniens emprisonnés
[Musique]
vous êtes avocat au bureau de Paris
membre du Conseil National des Barreaux
ancien membre du conseil de l'ordre des
avocats à Paris et co-fondateurs de
plusieurs collectifs franco-iraniens
présidents de l'association no roots
avec nous également en duplex Thierry
Coville chercheur à l'Institut de
relation internationales et stratégiques
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes spécialiste
de l'Iran auteur de ce livre l'Iran une
puissance en mouvement publié aux
éditions Eyrolles j'accueille également
Laetitia cruppard bonsoir Laetitia
éditorialiste politique bienvenue à vous
aussi le premier thème de ce débat la
première partie de ce débat forcément
c'est que se passe-t-il aujourd'hui en
Iran je disais dans mes titres le pays
est beaucoup moins sur les projecteurs
de l'actualité et pourtant et pourtant
on manifeste encore c'est ce que vous
voulez nous dire pour commencer
absolument on manifeste par tous les
moyens toutes les couches de la société
et de manière visible et et
organiser le centre comme dans votre
repostage ça a été dit le centre de
cette de ce mouvement contestataire ce
sont les universités la jeunesse et
maintenant large
soutient des professeurs qui sont de
plus en plus d'ailleurs embêtés il y a
eu plusieurs dizaines de professeurs qui
ont été
forcés de démissionner ou carrément
remercier si je puis dire et plus
intéressant encore c'est que la la
couche la plus croyante de de la
population iranienne à montrer sa
solidarité avec la jeune iranienne et
lors des commémorations de Moharram
c'est le moins sacré pour commémorer les
martyrs de l'islam qui en général
jusqu'à présent c'était la parade de du
pouvoir islamique donc ça c'est au cœur
de l'été vous êtes venus avec des images
avec une vidéo de cette manifestation
elle a été quoi détournée de son objet
par le mouvement révolutionnaire c'est
ça on va voir les images absolument et
après peut-être vous pouvez vous pouvez
vous dire
au sein de de la de la population comme
je vous dis la plus qui était
normalement la population la plus fidèle
à la République islamique de le
mouvement c'est depuis des années qui ne
le sont plus parce que je pense que la
contestation a atteint toutes les
couches de la société mais là ça a été
carrément il pointe du doigt le tyran
parce que je vais pas rentrer dans
l'histoire de l'Islam mais ils disent au
peuple pourquoi tu pleures les martyrs
les martyrs n'en peuvent plus juste
chasse le tyran que ça ce sont ce que on
veut des images en ce moment c'est ce
qu'ils sont en train de scander
absolument que sont devenus non non
c'est pas ça c'est pas cette c'est pas
cette vidéo je sais pas où ce qu'ils
l'ont
que vous nous aviez apporté mais c'est
pas grave donc on oublie cette vidéo sur
des choses qui arrivent donc vous nous
raconter un moment de manifestation
c'est un vrai défi au pouvoir absolument
et avec des noms avec en disant oh les
images où sont passés nos maçons où sont
passés non pourquoi l'autoroute tue pas
au peuple pourquoi tu sais absolument
fabuleux de voir et pas simplement dans
une ville dans toutes les villes du pays
et les meneurs de disons ceux qui ont
organisé ces manifestations et les
chanteurs avec des chants sublimes avec
une voix sublime qui fait vraiment froid
dans le dos ils ont été certains ont été
arrêtés le lendemain mais relâché parce
que le pouvoir ne peut pas attaquer les
croyances merci d'être venu avec avec
ces images c'est une vraie question sur
justement les suites judiciaires des
gagne hasard parce qu'on va parler de la
peur on va parler de
voilà de nous on a le sentiment que
finalement le mouvement mais à tort
j'entends ce que vous dites c'est
peut-être éteint à force de répression
du pouvoir il y a quand même beaucoup de
gens en prison des avocats eux-mêmes qui
sont en prison ça continue ça ne s'est
jamais arrêté c'était bien avant ce les
fait dramatiques il y a un an en réalité
déjà en 2019 il y avait eu beaucoup
d'exactions beaucoup d'avocats qui
avaient été arrêtés avec des
condamnations très graves ce qui se
passe l'aggravation de la situation
c'est que depuis un an maintenant les
ordres ont été mis sous tutelle et
les avocats ont maintenant c'est à dire
les défenses des personnes est assurée
par des gens qui sont pro-gouvernement
pour lesquels les plus graves ces
tribunaux d'exception qui a été mis en
place donc
cette résistance c'est vrai que les
manifestations continuent qu'elles se
sont diversifiées le peuple iranien est
un peuple résilient avec beaucoup
d'imagination et qui a réussi à devenir
solidariser et les avocats et la
population et les professeurs d'ailleurs
aussi parlé il y avait plus de 200
professeurs qui ont été arrêtés mais
alors on trouve encore des avocats si
j'ai bien compris activiste pour oser
défendre celles et ceux qui sont arrêtés
oui bien sûr on risque d'aller au même
emprise c'est ce qui se passe c'est
efficace alors ça dépend ce qu'on
appelle efficacité vu par notre notre
prisme ce n'est pas efficace dans le
sens où il n'obtiennent pas à gain de
cause devant les tribunaux pour autant
c'est efficace parce que il porte ils
font leur métier de porter la parole de
de porter la voix des gens qui ne l'ont
pas et ils nous permettent de dénoncer
ici de vous donner l'information parce
qu'ils arrivent eux à qualifier des
éléments c'est pas simplement le
scandale de ce qui m'arrive ce qui
arrive à ma famille c'est d'une manière
générale le l'opposition entre la
constitution même si on pourra parler si
vous voulez iranienne les lois
iraniennes et les agissements notamment
à travers la corruption j'accueille Aïda
Tavakoli bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
docteur en architecture présidente de
l'association
studient c'est quoi cette association
l'idée c'est de montrer que nous tous on
peut se considérer comme des comme des
Iraniens des étudiants iraniens prêts à
être solidaires c'est ça ce que vous
portez comme la première chose c'est de
dire que notre regard
de démo de citoyens de pays
démocratiques peut quand même peser sur
la situation en Iran est-ce que vous
croyez ça j'en suis convaincue oui tout
à fait donc l'idée de l'association
première c'est que 70% de la population
iranienne à moins de 40 ans et c'est la
population la plus instruite du
Moyen-Orient la moyenne d'instruction en
Iran est plus haute que la moyenne haute
occidentale donc c'est pour vous dire la
grande majorité et de l'écrasante
majorité sont étudiants et extrêmement
instruit avec un accès à l'information
aujourd'hui qu'on ne peut plus contrôler
et c'est notre grande chance aujourd'hui
en Iran donc l'idée de dance c'est de
montrer une solidarité de cette
génération étudiante par-delà les
frontières par
les cultures et les emplacements
géographiques puisque en réalité ce qui
est porté par femme liberté c'est ce qui
est porté par tous les mouvements de
jeunesse du monde et quand on parle de
féminisme d'écologie de défense des
droits humains des minorités on l'entend
absolument partout et c'est défendu par
notre génération bien au-delà des
frontières iraniennes alors je me tourne
merde envers Thierry Coville peut-être
pour essayer de comprendre au sein du
pouvoir
iranien
il est quand même ce pouvoir nous on a
le sentiment vu d'ici c'est peut-être
une question de bossien et je m'en
excuse qu'il est forcément fragilisé
parce qu'il se passe depuis un an est-ce
que c'est aussi simple que ça Thierry
Coville
sur pareil avec les rats oui et non
c'est sûr que il y a une crise de
légitimité politique en Iran
il y a eu des sondages qui sont sortis
même à l'intérieur du camp conservateur
quand les manifestations commencé qui
montraient que 80% de la population
iranienne même un tout petit peu plus
quelque part comprenait et trouver que
la présence des gens dans la rue étaient
une réponse à la crise que traversière
d'un autre côté
il faut bien comprendre que c'est pas
aussi simple que ça le pouvoir est en
place depuis un moment ils sont loin
d'être stupides c'est les plus durs qui
sont vraiment au pouvoir ils contrôlent
on l'a bien vu malheureusement que par
toutes les forces de sécurité ils ont
quand même encore une petite base
sociale qui les soutient qui est pour la
morale islamique on le sait ça et et
donc et ils ont vu à mon avis la clé de
pour comprendre ce qui se passe en Iran
c'est cette classe moyenne éduquée
auquel il a été fait référence
récemment là dans votre émission
les gens pensent à moi qui qui est pour
la démocratie parce que c'est vrai que
quelque part c'est le vent de l'Histoire
en Iran il a une société de plus en plus
moderne de plus en plus éduquée qui veut
les droits individuels la démocratie
l'état droit la séparation du religieux
du politique et cette classe moyenne
c'est la richesse de l'Iran classe
moyenne elle a pas complètement elle
sait pas jouer en mouvement autrement on
a eu des grèves massives en Iran donc
elle je pense que il y a un il y a la
répression c'est évident et d'un autre
côté il y a aussi la question de
l'alternative à ce qu'il y a
actuellement en Iran et je pensais un
article de Christopher de Bellegarde de
Guardian récemment il montrait bien se
dire quand vous savez pas ce qui va se
souvenir après vous n'êtes pas content
mais quelque part les gens même s'ils en
pensent pas moi ils sont restés chez eux
donc je pense que la clé pour comprendre
je vais l'appareil photo de cette
question c'est cette large classe
moyenne iranienne éduqué alors
effectivement on va continuer de
débattre là-dessus sur ce qui peut se
passer maintenant parce que on parle
d'une révolution mais le régime il est
il est pas tombé aujourd'hui il faut
arriver à schtroudi non non et je
j'abonde dans le parce que je viens de
dire Thierry covid c'est et il ne va pas
tomber demain néanmoins là contestation
ne va pas s'arrêter non plus je veux
dire tous les jours politique existe
déjà est-ce qu'il y a une opposition une
alternative il y a des il y a des
opposants il y a énormément d'opposants
à l'intérieur il y a beaucoup de
gouverner oui oui prêt à gouverner et
justement
au sein de ces opposants vous avez des
opposants de plus en plus radicaux c'est
à dire les le camp réformateur qui
pensait à une réforme et à une évolution
de l'Intérieur là ils disent il y a plus
beaucoup d'entre eux disent carré il y a
plus de possibilités de réforme et ils
se sont radicalisés c'est un phénomène
extrêmement intéressant je veux dire le
dernier communiqué de
mymotioni qui était donc le leader du
mouvement de 2009
a dit il faut en tir il faut en finir
avec avec la République islamique où il
faut en finir au moins avec le règne du
consulte avec le monsieur Kameni il peut
dire ça sans aller en prison il est déjà
sous surveillance et il est déjà malade
avec sa femme il dit il se porte mais
mais vous avez vu dans le monde les gens
parlent les gens les choses sortent ils
ne peuvent plus museler la population
tous les jours pardonnez-moi je dis ça
pour dire ce que justement a dit ma
jeune compatriote à côté et cette
jeunesse est magnifique pour nous pour
notre génération moi tout mon espoir
c'est cette jeunesse c'est que tous les
jours ils arrêtaient des étudiants et
tous les jours les communiqués des
collectifs il y a plusieurs objectifs
d'étudiants tous les jours on reçoit des
nouvelles des dernières nouvelles que
nous on relais sur le site de moi je
voulais juste vous donner quelques vous
donner la parole le débat est long vous
inquiétez pas on aura on aura le temps
de de l'alimenter mais moi je voudrais
vous proposer pour rester sur cette
thématique de de ce qui se passe en ce
moment aujourd'hui depuis quelques jours
quelques semaines et aussi évidemment à
l'occasion de cette date anniversaire
une vidéo qui a été publiée sur les
réseaux sociaux où on voit une femme qui
est prise à partie par un chauffeur de
taxi manifestement elle devait avoir son
son voile
baissé à l'arrière voilà ce qui se passe
je vous laisse regarder les images pour
commencer
[Musique]
donc voilà c'est une scène de vie en
Iran une jeune femme qui
ose enfin lui sort avec je pense c'est
parce que c'est c'est un une sorte de
barre de fer elle le frappe à coup de à
coup de chaussures bon c'est une
rébellion du quotidien d'une en quelque
sorte il y en a tous les jours des
scènes comme ça mais ça dit aussi une
forme de rupture de société qui est
toujours fracturé c'est ce que je je
vois aussi dans ces images votre avis
là-dessus et je vous redonne la parole
juste
oui bien sûr c'est une société qui est
fracturée mais je pense que ce qui
surtout fracturé c'est le mur de la peur
et en fait c'est ça c'est la grande
nouveauté et qui rend cette révolution
absolument inédite en Iran parce que
c'est pas le premier parce que la peur a
changé de camp en quelque sorte c'est
pas qu'elle a changé de camp c'est que
le mur de la peur et c'est brisé et
c'est que la peur illégitime la peur
existe et elle est absolument légitime
au vu de la répression absolument
brutale et sanglante du régime islamique
simplement la peur n'arrête plus et
c'est ça qui c'est que cette jeune femme
en allant s'asseoir dans un taxi sans le
voile c'est parfaitement à quoi elle
s'expose quand c'est un chanteur chante
retire ton voile et réponds à la peur et
à la violence avec la joie et la danse
il s'est parfaitement à quoi il s'expose
il sait que c'est la dernière chanson
qu'il va pouvoir enregistrer avant la
chute du régime et il le fait donc il y
a ce que je vois là évidemment on voit
une puissance on voit une une violence
atroce mais moi je vois énormément de
courage en fait dans cette vidéo et
c'est ça en fait qui transparaît
je si vous allez-y
je rebondis sur deux choses première
chose il y a quelques jours aussi
puisque vous êtes dans les vidéos on
voyait des jeunes avocats une vingtaine
de jeunes avocats qui étaient en train
de manifester qui dans la perspective de
l'anniversaire appelé aux libertés et à
la libération des personnes qui étaient
arrêtées d'ailleurs de tout leur
confrères ils savaient très bien qu'ils
allaient tout de suite eux-mêmes partir
en prison cette violence cette violence
vous la voyez vue par notre prisme
c'est quelque chose d'extraordinaire
très puissant maintenant c'est ce régime
qui a installé la violence depuis 40 ans
et la peur a changé parce qu'aujourd'hui
il y a une réponse
c'est à dire que il y a pendant très
longtemps le peuple a c'est laissé un
peu malmener sauf que maintenant il y a
une solidarité commune on n'est pas sur
l'histoire de c'est vrai que c'est la
première révolution on va dire féministe
et qui va avoir des conséquences moi je
le pense dans le monde entier si on va
jusqu'au bout et on va aller jusqu'au
bout mais c'est extraordinaire aussi
dans le sens où ces femmes qui font qui
vont dans la rue sans leur voile ça
commence en 2019 en 2016 même avec les
voiles qui étaient c'est pas quelque
chose de récent sauf qu'aujourd'hui la
violence elle n'est plus seulement
physique elle est aussi de montrer les
images elle est de dire les choses eux
le vivre ça comme une violence il y a
d'autres une autre explication moi j'ai
vécu en Iran de 2017 à 2020 pour
enregistrer la
fondation de mon père je ne portais pas
le voile alors privilège de l'âge et
c'était sous on ne m'embêtait pas ou
quand on m'arrêtait je disais écoutez je
vais le mettre mais dès que vous allez
tourner
mais néanmoins les taxis les chauffeurs
taxi me disaient je te tiens par la
barbichette les chauffants taxi me
disaient madame je vais perdre ma
licence il y a une pression économique
il y a les boutiques qu'on ferment donc
comment voulez-vous je le disais pour
vous je vais le mettre et il y a des
choses
exactement c'est pareil les étudiantes
madame le sait monsieur le sait on le
sait tous en Iran là la pression la
résistance c'est également une
résistance économique c'est pour ça que
nous on aide les familles financièrement
en Iran 120
000 euros
la caution ça va jusqu'à 120 000 jusqu'à
200000 euros une caution pour libérer
votre enfant de de prison
on peut aider en allant sur votre site
c'est
m². voilà beaucoup de personnes qui
sortent de présents qui peuvent raconter
qui peuvent témoigner ils sortent il
rentre il sortiront et des gens
témoignent sachant qu'ils vont retourner
tout de suite on a des cas comme ça il y
a beaucoup de choses beaucoup témoignent
mais vraiment aujourd'hui on peut dire
que la population iranienne est une
population journaliste dans le sens où
on nous envoie des films on nous envoie
des vidéos ils vont sur les réseaux
notamment ont fournit des VPN voilà avec
les téléphones c'est une des choses mais
par exemple pour l'économie une des
actions de résistance qui a été faite
c'est qu'à un moment donné les gens ont
dit on va aller retirer l'argent des
banques ils ont récupéré leur devise ils
les ont gardé à la maison ce qui a
fragilisé aussi justement sur l'économie
les Iraniens sont confrontés à une
situation qui est
la calamiteuse parce qu'il subisse une
inflam alors nous on a l'inflation mais
il subit une inflation qui est encore
plus forte quand François en Europe
regardez ces deux chiffres qui sont
donnés par le Centre iranien des
statistiques bon c'est un organe
officiel mais enfin bon on va on va
prendre ces chiffres quand même plus 46
% pour les loyers en un an ça c'est
automne 2022 par rapport à la même
période 2021 on va voir ce qu'il a ce
qu'il en est dans quelques semaines et
puis l'inflation là c'est le mois de
mars
49,7% d'inflation en plus par rapport
aux chiffres de de d'un an plus tôt sur
ce thème je vous propose d'écouter
plusieurs réactions de d'habitants de
terre regardez
moi je suis privilégiée j'ai un bon
emploi je gagne bien ma vie et pourtant
je ressens une pression économique
énorme 3 à 4 fois supérieur à celle de
l'année dernière
le marché connaît actuellement une
stagnation ontationniste les biens
devenant chaque jour plus cher
c'est de pire en pire les prix
augmentent tous les jours
Thierry covid je me tourne vers vous
dans quel état et l'économie iranienne
on sait qu'elle est déjà et depuis
longtemps affaibli par des sanctions
internationales
une crise économique grave en Iran donc
je pense quand même on voit dans les
chiffres et commence en 2018 et donc
c'est pas hasard en 2018 Donald Trump
sort de la Corse nucléaire et il
réimpose les sanctions américaines
contre l'Iran et notamment un embargo
pétrolier qui va réduire les
exportations de pétrole de l'Iran de
plus de 2 millions de barils par jour
début 2018 à 200000 baril donc divisé
par 10
au troisième trimestre 2020 avant
justement qui perdent qui quitte le
pouvoir Donald Trump depuis l'arrivée de
Joe Biden on voit bien que Joe Biden je
pense c'est dans sa stratégie de montrer
moi je ne suis pas
Donald Trump donc les exportations de
pétrole de l'Iran d'un petit peu remonté
on est quand même à un million de barils
par jour aujourd'hui ce qui est quand
même la moitié de ce qui peut faire donc
je pense que ça conduit le gouvernement
à moins d'argent il y a comme il y a un
déficit budgétaire énorme qui est
financé par la création monétaire la
monnaie s'effondrée donc ça conduit les
prix à l'importation ont fortement
augmenté donc je suis le la première à
reconnaître il y a plein de problèmes
l'Iran est une économie rentière
clientelliste qui est pas assez
dynamique mais le principal problème
c'est quand même les sanctions
américaines qui font qu'effectivement on
a une raison le gouvernement iranien les
donne des chiffres on est entre 45 et 50
% d'inflation la Banque mondiale dit
qu'il y a un tiers de la population
iranienne sous le seuil de pauvreté donc
effectivement l'inflation et le problème
principal avec également un autre
problème qui est une économie qui est en
faible de croissance depuis la sortie du
covid il y a deux trois pour cent de
croissance c'est pas suffisant pour
fournir des emplois et et on sait que le
taux de chômage baisse officiellement en
Iran mais comme dans d'autres pays il y
a beaucoup de gens qui sont sortis du
marché du travail en Iran notamment les
jeunes diplômés et on parle de plus en
plus d'un exode des cerveaux en Iran
donc je confirme ce que vous dites ça
c'est vraiment une économie en crise ce
qui explique aussi de mécontentements
actuels alors justement il a Tavakoli
est-ce que cette inflation peut attiser
la colère ou alors au contraire
finalement quand ça la préoccupation
principale c'est de payer son loyer ou
de remplir son frigo est-ce qu'on a le
temps de faire la révolution vous voyez
ce que je veux dire ça marche ensemble
ça marche ensemble c'est que évidemment
même on voit en ce moment que et puis
depuis en fait plusieurs années depuis
2018 comme le disait très justement
monsieur Coville c'est que on a même les
personnes qui idéologiquement pouvaient
être
affiliés au régime islamique aujourd'hui
non plus de quoi survivre et donc
évidemment qu'il y a une insatisfaction
qui qui traverse les générations et qui
traversent les classes sociales
aujourd'hui et
par rapport à ce que vous dites aussi
sur cet arbre aussi de l'économie c'est
vrai que c'est utilisé comme le disait
très justement fallait pas pour mettre
la pression justement pour éviter qu'il
y ait des soulèvements éviter qu'il y
ait des grèves éviter qu'il y ait des
protestations puisque on va menacer ceux
qui ont fait grève de fermer
définitivement leur magasin on va
menacer les chauffeurs de taxi de leur
retirer la licence
donc aujourd'hui la pauvreté est aussi
devenue une arme avec laquelle l'origine
joue
si tu la base il y a 70% de l'économie
qui entre les mains de proches du
gouvernement de proche corrompu et donc
c'est richesses là ne sont pas
distribuées et tout à l'heure on
entendait qu'il y avait pas il y a des
grèves aujourd'hui il y a des grèves qui
sont peut-être pas des grèves qui sont
au premier titre liés au début parce que
les fonctionnaires ne sont pas payés par
exemple liés aux événements mais qui
crée une convergence
alors on va parler de la répression
j'étais en train de régler ça avec la
régie je m'en excuse auprès de vous on
va on va voir d'abord un chiffre c'est
évidemment très difficile d'avoir un
bilan totalement précis parce que voilà
on est dans un régime qui qui cache ce
qu'il ce qu'il commet selon Amnesty
International près de 600 morts cette
manifestants exécutée et des exécutions
en opposition aux droits international
c'est ce que rappel président d'Amnesty
France lors d'une manifestation près de
l'ambassade d'Iran à Paris on écoute
Jean-Claude samouiller
et la peine de mort est utilisée pour
mater les manifestants en droit
international même pour les pays qui
n'ont pas ratifié le Protocole
additionnel concernant l'abolition de la
peine de mort les états la peine de mort
ne peut être utilisée en droit
international que pour les crimes de
sang
anticiper en quelque sorte avec premier
méditation et là c'est utilisé pour des
des raisons les plus bénignes notamment
manifestées ces libertés d'expression il
y a gagner hasard un mot là-dessus il y
a encore des je sais pas s'il y a un
couloir de la mort en Iran ou si ça ou
si ça va très vite entre la condamnation
et et par un tribunal et l'exécution
mais il y a des gens qui sont menacés de
mort après avoir été
condamnésif alors pendant un moment
donné la répression ils ont fait tout un
show c'était mis en scène comme il
communiquait dessus en pensant que ça
allait étouffer la Révolution le peuple
et en fin de compte ils sont rendus
compte que non enfin ça a même au niveau
international ça a Mobil avec l'echtag
notamment stop exécution vous voyez ça a
vraiment mobilisé beaucoup de personnes
maintenant on a des disparitions des
gens meurent il y a plus de 20 000
personnes on sait pas dans quelle
situation ils sont et maintenant on a
même des contraintes sur les familles
pour ne pas qu'ils donnent l'information
que la personne est décédée ou qu'elle
est disparu donc c'est vrai que les
chiffres sont vraiment à apprendre avec
beaucoup de précaution et je pense je
crains malheureusement qu'on découvre
comme ça a été fait en 2019
d'énormes exactions par la suite la
chose et oui a toujours un couloir de la
mort il y a toujours des condamnations
et il y a toujours des des gens qui
meurent y compris autrement que par la
pendaison alors on va parler des
réactions internationales et et d'abord
peut-être de réaction judiciaire je
propose à Audrey betas de nous rejoindre
sur ce plateau
bonsoir Audrey une plainte a été déposée
aujourd'hui même en France contre trois
dignités iraniens pour menaces de mort
et apologie du terrorisme expliquez-nous
quel est le but c'est une contre-attaque
Ess symbolique elle vise vous l'avez dit
trois dignitaires iraniens dont Haussen
salami que je vais vous montrer sur
l'image c'est le chef de l'armée
idéologique de l'Iran derrière cette
plainte pour menace de mort et apologie
du terrorisme il y a un collectif il
rend justice composé notamment d'avocats
franco-iraniens qui font partie de ce
qu'on appelle la diaspora et depuis plus
d'un an depuis depuis un an pardon
depuis la mort de Marsa Amélie il
recense conscieusement les exactions du
régime et toutes les menaces publics
proférées par ces hauts dignitaires
pourquoi parce qu'à chaque fois que la
diaspora iranienne se mobilise en France
ou dans n'importe quel autre pays comme
les manifestations qu'on a vu à l'image
juste avant et bien à chaque fois elles
sont suivies de menaces de la part de
l'Iran ce sont des fatsois déguisés
selon le collectif un exemple une sortie
des smileys
c'est le chef du Renseignement iranien
en 2022 voici ce qu'il disait et ce qui
a largement été repris sur dans la
presse détailliranienne qui compte a
joué un rôle dans les émeutes sera puni
partout dans le monde vous le voyez une
menace évidente en tout cas pour le
collectif iranjustice qui décide
aujourd'hui de riposter à une date
symbolique
nous c'est ce qu'on appelle des fatwa la
même d'ailleurs qu'avait lancé
l'ayatollah Romani sur Salman rushi on a
vu qu'elle a été d'ailleurs mise à
exécution et l'idée avec cette plainte
c'est de dire nous nous la diaspora nous
n'avons pas peur et vous ne parviendrez
pas à nous à combien vous l'avez entendu
c'était essentiellement symbolique même
si le collectif espère que les auteurs
des exactions pourront un jour être
poursuivi en France Thomas merci
beaucoup Audrey je me tourne de nouveau
vers vous irez
symbolique elle elle a aucune chance
d'aboutir comment comment vous réagissez
face à une action comme ça je la salue
parce que ce collectif j'en fais partie
et même si j'ai beaucoup moins actif
aujourd'hui dans ce collectif je sais le
travail extraordinaire qu'ils font
depuis le premier jour et qu'on a fait
depuis le premier jour
il y a beaucoup de choses qui sont
symboliques si on a le temps on parlera
des autres actions qui sont menées et le
foulard est un symbole aussi donc le
symbole est important pour montrer les
exactions on parle avec le langage
aujourd'hui on a AD pouvez aussi la en
France il existe une compétence du juge
pénal dans certaines matières notamment
le terme de cybercriminalité et on
utilise dans chaque pays les armes
juridiques le droit est une arme aussi
pour pouvoir non seulement dénoncer mais
condamné et on a bien vu que la quand on
dénonce avec du fondement légal quand on
arrive à se mettre au niveau de
compréhension du monde entier puisqu'on
a une base aujourd'hui l'Iran au siège à
l'ONU et donc elle l'a elle est censée
avoir une base légale commune elle est
censée respecter je vais la liste des
conventions internationales qui liront à
signer et les censé le respecter
dénoncer ça ce n'est pas simplement
symbolique et je vais redonner la parole
de documenter la répression c'est aussi
ce que vous cherchez à faire et on
disait que les chiffres sont forcément
imprécis mais voilà c'est des exécutions
c'est de la torture généralisée des
viols en prison c'est tout ça ce que
vous essayez de de noter de documenter
précisément peut-être pour des procès
éventuels qui sait absolument on
travaille avec le collectif et en
justice qui est dont je salue cette
action et puis toutes les actions qu'ils
ont menées depuis un an qui sont
absolument extraordinaires et on
travaille avec eux justement parce
qu'effectivement dans l'association
on collecte l'intégralité des données
dont on dispose à travers les réseaux
sociaux sur la répression à l'encontre
des étudiants aujourd'hui on a une liste
de plus de 847 étudiants qui ont été
emprisonnés et qui aujourd'hui sont
épuisés cette liste est mise à jour donc
on a leur nom leur prénom leur lieu
d'études le moment de l'arrestation et
si ils sont toujours arrêtés s'ils ont
été libérés sous caution ou pas et
toutes ces données là sont extrêmement
précieuses on a aussi les données sur
les empoisonnements des écoles de filles
en moins de 6 mois
presque 900 écoles de jeunes filles ont
été attaquées au gaz chimique
donc c'est une ampleur absolument
qui démontre à quel point c'était
prémédité à quel point c'était massif et
ça ne peut être que l'oeuvre d'une
organisation qui est structurée et qui
financièrement a les moyens d'agir sur
l'ensemble du territoire iranien donc on
a recueilli des échantillons avec l'aide
de plusieurs associations
internationales des échantillons de
cheveux et de vêtements pour pouvoir
analyser du coup ce gaz
identifier le type de gaz et pouvoir
ensuite effectivement continuer avec des
procédures légales qui un crimineront le
régime
ça n'empêche pas le régime de continuer
pardon d'être je n'ai pas en cause le
l'important c'est la qualité de tout ce
que vous faites mais ce régime est
toujours en place et enfin vous voyez ce
que je veux dire a-t-il peur de des
sanctions internationales ou d'un
éventuel procès écoutez oui et non oui
et non mais ce qui fait la différence
c'est l'intérieur nous on fait la même
des choses sur le site de Moha vous avez
depuis le début on a essayé de donner
les noms des étudiants etc ces étudiants
sont emprisonnés ils continuent je vais
vous donner juste un chiffre le mois
prochain enfin le la semaine prochaine
il va y avoir un bilan le bilan que les
étudiants de l'intérieur nous ont donné
sur les exactions les arrestations etc
dans une seule province je veux pas
faire tout le bilan parce que vous
l'aurez et puis dans une seule province
il y a eu 8000 blessés dont 580
personnes qui ont perdu un œil et
néanmoins une de ces personnes qui a
perdu un œil une parce que tout surtout
les femmes on dit si c'était à
recommencé on recommencera c'est une
comédienne qui une semaine après est
monté sur les planches et la raconter
son histoire elle a été arrêtée et la
continuité
l'apprécieranienne a fait état de cela
et je viens sur ce qu'a dit bon je ne
compatriote ici présent qui est
extrêmement important c'est que la
jeunesse iranienne en ce moment
et très légaliste de revendications qui
viennent dans toute la population et
notamment les anciens gardiens
d'évolution qui sont parce que il y a eu
énormément de d'anciens gardiens de
gardiens de la révolution jeune qui
démissionne ou qui partent ou qui fuit
ou qui s'enfuit deux revendications
abolition de la peine de mort
deuxièmement arrêter nous mais au moins
soyez fidèle à votre propre
constitutions
de ces arrestations 20
000 selon 22
000 vous avez dit 600 personnes morts
selon les sources du support 1500
personnes dont des enfants
c'est pour vous dire que quand je dis
les donc la différence c'est l'intérieur
et quand l'intérieur on n'arrête pas de
dire que il y a pas d'opposition
organisée il y a un de mes jeunes qui
est en train de faire une une sélection
de peintures que j'espère qu'un jour on
pourra les exposer qui s'appelle sans
tête il dit justement l'importance de
cette révolution c'est qu'il y a pas de
tête il était son c'est toute la
jeunesse en général et la population
alors l'intérieur vous nous dites mais
je vais pardon je reprends la parole
intérieur vous nous le dites mais on va
continuer de s'intéresser aussi à
l'extérieur avec vous Laetitia peut-être
pour un zoom sur la réaction de la
classe politique française comment
c'était le mobilisée depuis un an pour
soutenir les manifestants les
manifestants iraniens on peut dire que
c'est quand même assez rare pour la
classe politique française dans son
ensemble il y a eu un consensus pour
défendre les manifestants les soutenir
les manifestants iraniens et ça s'est
fait en deux temps ça c'est intéressant
à observé comme stratégie d'abord sur
Twitter alors il y a eu Yaël Brown
vivait la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale puis Valérie Pécresse
président de la région de France puis
Olivier fort le patron du Parti
socialiste puis d'autres personnalités
comme ça en suivi ont écrit sur Twitter
en leur nom des messages de soutien
direct au peuple et le mouvement de
parlementaire aussi oui oui twitter n'a
pas été juste choisir au hasard puisque
tout a commencé sur les réseaux sociaux
et ça a commencé là et ça c'est propagé
aussi sur les réseaux sociaux et juste
il y a des têtes c'est important sur les
réseaux sociaux parce qu'il y a une
centaine de parlementaires députés
sénateurs qui ont accepté de parrainer
les manifestants et qui ont publié
justement les visages des personnes qui
étaient arrêtées et menacées de mort
avec ce hashtag stop
en anglais exécution en Iran en français
mais oui vous avez raison il y a eu des
communications aussi beaucoup plus
directes le 11 novembre avec le
président de la République qui s'engage
et qui reçoit à l'Élysée une délégation
de femmes iranienne des combattantes en
place contre le régime en place et il
utilise le mot révolution Emmanuel
Macron pourquoi c'est important Thomas
parce que le régime qui a regardé
apparemment les interviews d'Emmanuel
Macron sur France 2 et France Inter
c'était filmé aussi c'en est servi dans
sa propagande a pris des images et s'en
est servi pour dire regardez ils se sont
les Français et les
Occidentaux en général qui en gros on
sent là pour instrumentaliser cette
révolution en soi-même les instigateurs
les parlementaires eux aussi ont
communiqué un soutien marqué oui alors
une fois c'était le 4 octobre elle a
tenu à avoir quelques mots avant les
questions au Gouvernement on va
l'écouter la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale je voudrais évoquer avec vous
la mémoire de Madame
Marsa à minet c'était le 16 septembre
dernier en Iran
brutalement arrêté au nom d'une supposée
vertue pour une simple mèche de cheveux
qui dépassait de son voile elle est
décédée
depuis des femmes des hommes et toute la
jeunesse d'Iran dont il faut admirer
l'incroyable courage exprime leur soif
de liberté
il y en a eu d'autres des aplanissements
dans l'hémicycle le 14 novembre
l'Assemblée nationale vote une
résolution au soutien de soutien au
peuple iranien condamnant notamment
l'interdiction des libertés des droits
des femmes on se souvient des mots forts
cette fois-ci de la ministre des
Affaires étrangères Catherine Colonna
qui a scandé le slogan des manifestants
femmes vie liberté là encore les députés
dans leur globalité elle avait applaudit
puisque deux jours plus tard le 16
novembre diffusé surtout les réseaux
sociaux quasiment dessinateurs beaucoup
de réseaux sociaux une vidéo on voit
notamment Nathalie Goulet c'est matrice
udi de l'Orne qui est à l'origine de
cette initiative et puis d'autres
sénateurs qui sont là pour soutenir les
Iraniens c'est important les réseaux
sociaux encore une fois je le répète
dans cette à gauche comme à droite les
réactions ont été unanimes écoutez oui
on peut parler d'un certain consensus
mais c'est vrai quand même qu'à gauche
le soutien était moins audible et moins
visible seul particularité peut-être le
Parti socialiste qui est constant dans
son soutien puisque à deux reprises il a
fait voter en conseil national de
résolution en faveur de la révolution
iranienne en octobre 2022 et puis en
juin la dernière manche juin 2023 il a
réitéré cette
résolutions
de la réception à l'Élysée d'Emmanuel
Macron pourquoi
parce que je suis un peu sur je reste
sur ma faim comment
on est la France a une très belle image
moi je me rappelle quand j'étais jeune
en Iran on m'a vite parlé de la
Révolution française et quand vous dites
en Iran que vous êtes à la Sorbonne par
exemple des lumières comment est-ce
qu'on peut imaginer mettre autant
d'énergie et prendre autant de risques
le 11 novembre et qu'on se retrouve
aujourd'hui le 15 septembre et qu'on
puisse s'imaginer que concrètement rien
n'a pas vraiment encore été mis en place
et que c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup
d'initiatives qui sont prises par les
uns et par les autres j'ai vu par le
régime et vu par le régime mais je
j'attends moi je de mon pays d'adoption
et que je moi ça fait je suis arrivé à
11 ans j'en ai 52 et j'aurais aimé
j'aimerais plus de clarté parce que la
population iranienne et le monde entier
demande la clarté sur toute la France
si vous pouvez me permettez juste une
seconde la France a vraiment une
histoire avec l'Iran et que c'est un
pays civiste à la base et que comme il y
a quand même partie France bien sûr il
était donc c'est vrai qu'on a une
attente particulière de ce pays des
droits de l'homme Thierry covid je vais
peut-être terminé ce débat avec vous
justement sur le est-ce que l'Iran
finalement bénéficie d'une sorte de
alors je sais pas d'indifférence
internationale je vais évidemment pas
employer le mot soutien mais le régime
j'ai dit l'Iran mais le régime iranien
au pouvoir bénéficie d'une sorte
d'indifférence internationale est-ce que
vous diriez ça
non pas du tout je pense que objet qu'on
en a parlé on vient d'en parler il est
difficile de trouver un pays qui a été
aussi sanctionné client
la Corée du Nord mais ensuite il y a
l'Iran donc c'est là où mais depuis un
an vous voyez ce que je veux dire depuis
un an si on attend que la communauté
internationale pèse
je pense qu'effectivement
je pense qu'il y a derrière les discours
des pieds occidentaux il y a la question
du nucléaire iranien donc il y a l'idée
que
effectivement la répression a été
condamnée il y a l'idée aussi que si on
va trop loin avec les rangs notamment il
y avait cette idée de mettre les passes
d'un rangs sur les organisations
terroristes le risque est ce que l'Iran
il y a des gens qui veulent ça en Iran
arrête ces discussions sortent du traité
de nos proliférations et l'Iran face
cavalier seul vers à la bombe nucléaire
alors c'est un scénario qui est pas
forcément le plus probable mais il
existe et donc je pense que ça a
fortement freiné
les tentatives d'être beaucoup plus dur
avec les rang avec l'idée que il faut
garder ce calque des canaux de
communication avec l'Iran bon en plus on
avait des otages la France avait des
otages et en plus surtout il y a cette
question nucléaire iranien aller à la
limite je pense que la question de
l'aide de l'Iran
à la Russie pour la guerre en Ukraine
publicité on va dire parce que
malheureusement plus de condamnations de
la part des pays occidentaux que que la
répression n'irables pour répondre à
votre question je pense la question du
nucléaire fait que les pays occidentaux
n'ont pas osé à aller trop loin merci
beaucoup merci à tous je rappelle le nom
de vos associations
motion.com si on veut voilà aider celles
et ceux qui sont confrontés à des
procédures judiciaires oui
c'est ça ça veut dire quoi nowhouse
Nouvel An Nouvel An ben voilà on
souhaite une un nouvel an et une
nouvelle ère pour pour lire entier et
covid votre livre l'Iran une puissance
en mouvement et publié aux éditions
Eyrolles merci à tous encore une fois
d'avoir participé à ce débat